hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to a video that will show you
guys how cherish at actually kind of
works okay so you've obviously seen me
make the application but I've never run
it on separate computers on separate
network stuff like that so I wanted to
show you guys how it's gonna work this
is pretty much myself no I don't usually
have these two laptops in front of me
but uh from now this is kind of all my
setup looks like that's not what the
video was about basically this is where
I make all my er all my videos anyway
point is we've got China Chad what the
server running on this desktop here if I
focus is there real quick you can see it
says now this iPhone there you go so it
says that I've just run the server I
basically just started the server using
using the Windows command prompt here
using a port 81 line 2 you can see the
command line arguments right there after
the name of course with a jar file and
and you can see there that it's up it
started the server on port a 192 now
we're on this computer this is obviously
the same computer with servers running
I'm going to just pretty much log in as
the name Jana and you can see the IP
address I vented his localhost and then
the point of day 1 line 2 of course
because a 192 now local host of course
al refers to this specific computer
because server's running on the same
computer is declined so let's go ahead
and try and connect to that and see what
happens
so login alright cool so it says I hear
that yarn connected over here in the
server and then in our client it says
that is successfully connected fantastic
if we say something like hey hey ok that
good answer you can say that it's
actually going to appear on the on the
on the server here and it's also gonna
appear in the client everything worked
wonderfully great that's that's lordcool
kind of connection that's pretty sure
you guys already knew that now let's go
ahead and try it on a laptop ok so let's
try it on this on this windows Ultrabook
that I've got here it's just just a
serious altra book that I've had for
about probably met a year and a half by
now
um anyway point is there it is right
call this one ultrabooks just so you
guys can differentiate it from the other
one the IP address here that I've
entered is the local
ipv4 address of my desktop ok so that's
the internal IP address of my of my
desktop because this of course is on the
same network they're both connected to
the same router which happens to be
here now let's go ahead and try and
connect so the port of course is still a
192 cuz that's where the server's
running and I'm the IP addresses 0.10
because that's the IP address of this
desktop here let's go ahead and hit the
login button see what happens alright so
over here white space we've got we've
got
ultrabook connected okay so there you go
we're in let's go ahead and says here
that we've successfully connected let's
go ahead and say something hit enter and
check this out over here on our client
we've got ultrabook saying that all
right if we say something on our desktop
so I'm gonna type something on my
desktop all right and then I'm gonna hit
enter there it is you can see it's
instant as well no delay okay that's
sweet now over here I've also got my
math set up this is actually what I use
to record now watch our program because
I decided though I'm mad for no apparent
reason um okay so over here I've named
it map just cuz this is a Mac again I'm
connected to the same ip address as you
can see with the port a 192 I'm gonna
hit login and of course as you might
expect successfully connected it says
here that Mac connected and if we say
something on Mac follow blah hit answer
you can say it's gonna appear everywhere
on every single computer and one now if
I say something ultrabook hit enter if I
say something on my desktop and hit
enter here then it's gonna appear
everywhere and you guys can basically
talk like that now this works throughout
the internet not just of course on a
local network but you guys can see that
Cherno chat really does work and the
other thing that we can test out that I
completely forgot about it's if we have
file online users you can see who's
online okay so we've got yarn ultrabook
Mac I'll go ahead do the same thing here
file online users you can see we going
up the on/off book Mac and this works
out of the box on Windows and math by
the way because it's random Java I
didn't have to change anything I
exported it the exact same file that I
exported runs on both systems flawlessly
so that's just that's just Java at its
finest like that that's pretty much why
Java exists okay and then you can see
that same case here right if I was to
close the Ultrabook one right let's go
ahead and with my mouse there it is if
we click if we close this Ultrabook
window here so we disconnect I'm just
go ahead show you guys this view on my
Mac here if I close this window on my
ultrabook then you can say that we
disconnect and same thing reflects here
so everything works exactly like I
intended it to of course it works I mean
African or this application but some
that's the network's a programming
series if you guys haven't checked out
Trinidad that's what it is alright so
what I've done now is I've logged into
my server this is actually the same
server that runs my website the chair
calm and if this iPhone focuses here
real quick which it's not doing come on
bro work with me
oh don't seriously come on I need some
manual focus on this thing there you go
ok so you can see that I'm basically for
Java John and Church have served or
Johanna you can see that that's the
command I'm executing I'm starting it on
port 81 9 - I want to go ahead and hit
enter on that and you can see here that
it says service started on port a 192 so
now the other thing I'm basically gonna
change is you can see on the Ultrabook
here I've got I've got the name source
reported a 100 but the IP address now is
the channel calm okay cuz that's the IP
address of my server so as I hit login
here it's gonna tell me that I
successfully connected and over here on
my server it's gonna tell me cuz I'm
connected via SSH that ultrabook here
with that I be connected great okay so
let's go ahead and do the same thing on
our desktop here so there's the veterans
head on our desktop so Y on the channel
combo wha and when I turn of course as I
hit login on that you're gonna see over
here that Y on connected brilliant
awesome okay so now that remains is the
Mac same the children become you can see
that IP address there and at port at 192
because of course the DNS server
resolves the general come to the actual
IP address of my server so you can type
in a string such as you know exactly
like the same thing that we did with
local horse we didn't type in 127.0.0.1
we talked in local horse and we did a
similar thing
the same thing with the website if
you've got a DNS server of course that
resolves that now that being said let's
go ahead and join here and we're gonna
say if force is here that is
successfully connected you know you're
going to see that Mac connected so now
we've got three people here ok and now
it's actually going through the services
well I can leave this on bloody 24/7 ok
and we'll still work fine so on if we
type in something like auto nurse its
something like that on my desktop I
wanna show you guys the ultra before you
hit enter you can see it's gonna appear
here it's gonna appear on the server as
well this is running this isn't running
Windows or anything by the way it's
running Debian baby in 6 I think which
is of course the distribution of Linux
so the Java you know in a problem for
Java R works fine as long as you go
trough or install the course on Davian
so then your um also uh if I say
something here for example let's show
the Matthew you guys can see that uh
it's gonna appear here as well and
basically I'm just showing you guys that
uh we're gonna incoherently chat to each
other
through our different um through our
different systems again and that works
absolutely fine it works really really
really faster you guys can probably hear
when I hit enter so this is the this is
the Ultrabook I've typed something on my
desktop here as you can say and then on
my ultrabook I'm just gonna go ahead
sorry on my desktop I'm gonna hit enter
you guys will hear the clack check how
fast that is it's like I don't know 200
milliseconds of ping which is probably
around the set the same thing because
this service look at it and you know and
so like city I think it wishes in of
course the US and is in Utah so there
you have 7 Utah no problem for us it
works fine so anyway that is pretty much
it and of course if I go to online users
and everything it's gonna work fine it's
gonna tell me he's online
if I go ahead and shut off my my
ultrabook here I'll just close it you
can see that it updates and it's fun
okay now climb ultrabook disconnected
it's a day your that is the thing that's
my IP address I'm gonna have to hide
that oh that is the that is the that is
the game that is the only game but that
is the current track line of course you
guys did enjoy the video please hit the
like button now in the UM in the next
this isn't really an episode but I'm
actually gonna put out a video tomorrow
that will show you guys how to get it to
run on your Linux server or other server
so um be sure to stay tuned for that and
also cover exporting the application but
anyway I hope you guys enjoy this video
if you did please hit like button I'll
see you guys later goodbye